القوات الاوكرانيه وبتحديد التحقيق
الاوكراني وخبراء التحقيق التابعين لمكتب
الادعاء العام بخرسن همم في اطار همم
استقاء ادله عن جرائم الحرب تمكروا من
العثور على اربعه مواقع
همم يفترض ان تكون مباني مدنيه ولكنها
استخدمتها القوات الروسيه عندما كانت
موجوده في المنطقه لتعذيب المدنيين
والجنود وغيرهم من لا يولون القوات
الروسيه
طبعا هذه الادله تضاف الى السجلات الادله
الاخرى التي حصلت عليها وتمكنت من كشف
عنها القوات الاخرانيه همم لادله جرائم
الحرب قبل احالتها الى القضاء الاوكراني
وفي محاوله ايضا لتدوير هذه القضايا جرائم
الحرب على المحاكم الدوليه طبعا بالاضافه
الى ذلك همم تصعيد الامني لا يزال متواصلا
حيث هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه ان الانسحاب الروسي كان سببه
الرئيسي هو تعزيز جبهه بخموت في الدنيا
وفيديفكا ولكن مع ذلك يستمر القصف الروسي
في خرسون تحديدا حيث اكد النائب مدير
المكتب الرئاسي بان عدد من الجرحى سقط
ضحايا فيها في عمليه قصف روسي كما ايضا
كما اكدت اكد نائب مسؤول في مجلس الاقليمي
على همم عدد من الجرحى في قصف استهدف مخبز
في همم مدينه خرسا وكذلك بمن تحتيه في
مدينه خرسا ايضا هذا بالاضافه الى وصول
الاولى المساعدات الانسانيه من الاتحاد
الاوروبي هذا اليوم الذي قدم العديد من
المساعدات الماليه وكذلك همم المساعدات من
اكل كل الماء وكذلك التوفير الكهرباء
والانترنت فضلا عن وصول المولدات همم طاقه
الاسبوع المقبل بالاضافه ايضا الى وصول
اولى مساعدات اليونيسيف خاصه المساعداتهم
الاطفال كال- الملابس وكذلك الاغطيه
وغيرها من المساعدات التي تبلغ 80 الطنا
من الامدادات الانسانيه
الروسي من حدث نووي هناك والمخاوف الدوليه
الكبيره ما التفاصيل لديك ما المعلومات في
اوكرانيا اليوم عن اخر التطورات في ذا
فويس
نعم رجاء منذ قليل
رئيس بتروكوتين رئيس شركه ااه الانيرجو
اتوم الشركه
الانتاج الطاقه النوويه الاوكرانيه برا
القوات الاوكرانيه من اي اتهام بشان
استهداف محطه النوويه وذلك
بذريعه ان القوات الروسيه تستخدم محطه
الذكوريج النوويه كقاعده عسكريه وانه هناك
ما لا يقل عن 500 جندي في هذه همم محطه ان
المخابئ الامنه التي يفترض استخدامها
للائتمان من اي حادث النووي هناك يوجد
فيها العتاد العسكري الروسي وكذلك
المراكب المركبات المدرعه
اخرى في هذه المخاطر النوويه ولذلك
الروس يعلمون ان القوات الاوكرانيه لن
تستهدف محطه زبوريج ان نوويه لذلك
يستخدمونها كقاعده عسكريه روايه طبعا
الروايه الاكرانيه والموقف الاوكراني
يعتبر ان هذه ان الروس والقوات الروسيه
تضرب محطه الزبوريجيا ووصلنا فاتت هذه
الضربات في خانه الرد الانتقامي على
الانسحاب انسحاب القوات الروسيه من خلص
وعلى المكاسب الميدانيه التي حققتها
اوكرانيا كما كان الشان في شهر اغسطس
الماضي عندما تقدمت القوات الاوكرانيه في
كيف وهو نفس الموقف الذي تتبناها الرئاسه
الفرنسيه والرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل مكرم
من ناحيه اخرى القوات الروسيه تعتبر بان
العمليه الضرب همم
هي عمليه استفزاز اوكرانيه بحثا لكن بين
هذا وهذاك هناك الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه وخاصه على راسها رفع روسي الذي
ادانا اولا بشده هذه الضرباته ولكنه يجد
نفسه في موقفا حارس باعتبار انه زار مع
وفد مختص في سلامه النوويه في شهر همم
سبتمبر الماضي المحطه النوويه وكان وحدد
وعين مهمه وبعثه دائمه في الوكاله الدوليه
الطاقه الذريه يفترض ان تكون همم تراقب
هذه المحطه من اي سلامه من اي همم كارثه
نوويه تهديد نووي الا ان
ان طرفي النزاع لم يابا بهذه بهذه العمليه
وهذه وهذه المهمه النوويه وتتواصل وتتواصل
الضربات طبعا رفع الجروسي قال ان هناك من
لا يفرق بين الهدف العسكري وبين الهدف
النووي وهذا غير عادي وقال لحسن الحظ انها
لان محطه النوويه لم يتم استهدافها ولكن
المره المقبله لن يكون هناك حظ شكرا لك
شكرا وسيم